Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you so much for joining us for today.
It's our third episode!
Are you surprised?
It's the third episode.
I don't know.
I'm just happy with every new FUWAMOCO Morning you know.
Ruffians, did you think we could do it?
Well... Moco-chan, what is FUWAMOCO Morning?
Ah, FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
And hosted by us!
What's your name?
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring you a smile and start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Right above me!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU!
It was a bit hard because we didn't want to say too much yesterday, but it's hard not to.
Actually... De-den!
We reached 1 million views on our cover archive too!
Thank you!
Another amazing milestone.
We reached all together.
Thank you Ruffians.
Thank you.
BAU BAU BAU!
We're really blown away by all your enthusiasm.
Thank you.
I think we talked about it a lot, but we are really, really excited to be able to share Kaibutsu with you.
And actually, when we were really, really nervous for our debut, kind of waiting.
Whenever we watch Kaibutsu over, we think about what your reaction would be like.
That gave us the courage to kind of get through our little jitters here and there, right?
Again, we'd like to say a big thanks to Omeka-san for the amazing videos.
Hi-san Fred the Killer!
It's really killer, right?
I really like it.
It's cute and cool.
Right?
I can be cool.
I can be cool sometimes too.
And also to Hamahiro-san for the magical vocal mixing.
It's so amazing.
You know, actually we let Mamban Puppy listen to it.
And now she's been hounding us because she really wants to listen to it off of YouTube.
Since she doesn't really use it that much.
We're really happy that she's enjoying it too, you know?
Not just the Ruffians, but also Mama Puppy.
I just keep on doing it.
No, YouTube has a place for Mama Puppy, so... You'll have to listen there.
Is it okay to say?
Is it?
Maybe.
Maybe?
Actually, Ruffians, because of all your support, we have good news!
We started working on our next cover song!
BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
We hope you look forward to it, but please, if you like Kaibutsu, we'd really like it if you could listen to it lots and lots.
Yeah, yeah.
Continually, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
One million!
One million, one.
Next!
We have...
De-den!
We talked about this last time, but we want you to know something.
We're really, really thankful that you've taken so many listens to our feed.
We've seen a lot of your thoughts being shared on Twitter.
We're really, really happy to be able to hear your thoughts.
What you liked.
Those kind of things.
We had a lot of fun with it.
It was a new experience for us.
I think doing more voice packs is something we'd really
Ruffians!
What was your favorite?
Like we said, there's the morning voice, and the goodnight voice, unique voice.
And just because we're twins, it doesn't mean it's the same.
I think they're very different.
They're very different.
Morning voice!
Mococo morning one!
It definitely has flavor, right?
Flavor, right.
Very flavorful.
Morning voice!
But we really, really want to be able to do a lot more and be able to get more opportunities to record more voicebacks in the future.
I'm not sure if we mentioned it before, but we really, really enjoyed recording them to a surprising level.
When we were done, we were like, that was really, really fun.
I actually really, really, really enjoyed that.
I want to do that more.
I was thinking though, like, if we were to produce, like, our own custom hololive voice talent, make a sample and record it too, what would we want to do?
Ruffians, what would you like?
Yeah, good idea!
A maid cafe!
Maybe that's kind of plain.
I could do like a Isekai voice.
Oh, you're awake now.
You've been sleeping for five centuries.
You hit your head really hard.
And now you're in a very plain world.
A plain world?
I was going to say, we have to go slay the dragon.
You know, that kind of thing.
No?
Well... What about like a voice pack that's just filled with a hundred different variations of BAU?
You know, like... Okay, Moco-chan.
My request.
Say... You're waking up your older brother, but it's BAU.
BAU BAU!
Okay, what about for me?
I made you some food.
Would you like some BAU BAU?
Is BAU BAU in it already?
No, it's BAU BAU.
I made you some food.
BAU BAU.
Yeah.
BAU!
B-B-B-BAU!
Yeah, like that.
Right!
Would you like a voice pack like that?
Good manners.
You buy it, it'll be considered.
Please support us with the voice packs too, okay?
So we can make more and more and have more opportunities for that.
Thank you!
Well, there's been another misunderstanding.
Why?
You think we'd be better than that?
You know, too many misunderstandings.
It happened.
It happened again.
Well, this time, it happened during a stream of Little Witch Nobita.
Moco-chan and Navi, we share your thoughts when it comes to squeamism.
There's a misunderstanding, okay?
There's a misunderstanding.
You know, I said that the best combo is Tsukumizu plus Scarf, but what I really meant to say was that Tsukumizu plus Scarf plus Glasses is the best.
Yeah.
Right!
But why are the glasses so important, Moco-chan?
Because!
It makes it better.
It makes it better?
BAU.
What?
Why are you laughing?
This is very important.
You agree, right?
You need to make sure you don't misunderstand, okay?
But for the record, I, Fuwawa, would also like to clarify.
I said that Sukumizu and socks is the best.
But what I really meant was that Tsukumizu by Socks with a banded over top is the best.
Right.
Even better, you know, if there's a green bangle that goes around the wrist.
Green bangle.
A bit translucent.
You might think this is ultra specific, but this is how it should be.
This is the proper way.
You'll understand in time, I think.
You get it, right.
Understand!
Understood.
Okay, good.
No misunderstanding anymore, right?
Unfortunately... We have another misunderstanding.
Yeah.
And this one... It's a big... A big misunderstanding.
Big misunderstanding.
No, uh... One that we haven't really been able to talk about yet.
No.
No, because it's just that big.
Yeah.
De-den.
During the end of our Rock n' Rawr Party, you know, when there was around 30,000 viewers watching, I might have made a statement about... You have to say it!
You have to!
Moco-chan, you say it!
A tone.
A tone!
A tone for it.
I might have said something like, we're gonna put the dog into the monkey and make him Donkey Kong.
But there's a good reason why I said this!
Moco-chan, you explain.
Well, Fuwawa says that she meant it like you put the play in the PlayStation, right?
The X in the Xbox, or the pawn in the ring sort of thing, right?
Yeah, those kind of things.
You know, that's why I said it.
That's why I said we're gonna put the dog in the monkey and play Donkey Kong.
It makes sense, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Right.
What I said was completely sensical.
It makes sense!
You agree, right?
Right?
I'm not seeing any question marks.
Nope.
There is no reason for laughter.
No.
It makes sense.
I can get it now.
Yes, you're right!
Thank you!
Unfortunately, I think these sort of misunderstanding statements are a normal thing for huawuas.
I guess you can probably look forward to more of those misunderstandings!
I hope it doesn't happen, but... It might happen.
Will there ever be a FUWAMOCO Morning without misunderstandings, though?
I hope so!
I hope so, too!
Let's hope for that, okay, Ruffians?
No more misunderstandings.
Just a normal, normal FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
You know, a good day with no misunderstandings to start it off with.
Yeah.
No dogs and monkeys.
No dogs, no dogs and no monkeys.
No.
Good.
No more understanding over here.
No more misunderstanding.
Yeah, you understand.
It's about a misunderstanding.
Okay.
Actually, we wanted to share a little bit more about ourselves today with you, you know?
I know we've mentioned it here and there, but your host, FUWAMOCO, is us.
We're from a place called the Northwest Passage.
You know, that's our home.
The FUWAMOCO home.
Moco-chan, do you have a drawing?
I do.
I have a couple drawings.
Oh, let's share them.
This is kind of what the Northwest Passage looks like.
Listen!
The Northwest Passage is located within the Makai.
The Makai is like the Demon World.
And that's why it's in the PT Time Zone.
And you know, the Northwest Passage is really nice.
It is kind of boring at the same time though.
It can be a bit rainy.
There's lots of trees.
It's okay though, you know?
I think the human world is much more exciting though.
Nature, it's a bit more grand than the human world, I think.
We have nice weather too, but there's a lot of rain too.
But it's really pretty when it is nice, you know?
I think, you know, there's a lot of...
Trees.
A lot of trees.
Rocks.
And some water too.
And you know, it's sparkly when it's bright.
I like that.
And you know when we were just puppies, it was really fun playing outside.
Playing in all the seasons.
I think maybe the puppies now don't really do that as much.
But, I don't know.
I'm happy that we were able to do that.
Right!
Yeah, more and more demon puppies.
Demon dog puppies.
They're just stuck on the devices, you know?
You know, how are you supposed to make
It's good to have something that you like that's an indoor thing, you know, for maybe when it's raining.
But, you know, it's good to go outside.
There's a lot of skills that you can build up there.
If you like lessons, you'll be like, oh, I miss those days when I could run free in the grass and the trees, you know?
But the internet can also help with other skills, too.
But other important skills need to be developed offline, too, right?
We should all be careful of how we spend our time online and limit it to what's important to us, right?
Balance.
Balance is key.
Yeah.
As for Demon Dogs, there's a lot of different Demon Dogs.
We all undergo different training and take on different kinds of tasks.
But for us, we're Demon Guard Dogs.
And actually, there's a job that every Demon Guard Dog wants.
Ruffians, you know maybe?
Okay well, it's actually protecting the big door, the gate to the Moco.
That's the number one sort of job.
It's kind of like becoming an astronaut in the human world.
Every parent puppy wants their little puppies to do that job, you know?
We're only the very, very best guard dogs get chosen for that position.
It's still just, you know, a bit of a dream for us, but I think, you know, we're really, really happy right now to be here with you, protecting your smiles.
We're gonna do our best and focus on that.
There's also other kinds of Demon Dogs too, you know?
Not just Demon Guard Dogs, right?
There's Demon Police Dogs, Demon Dentist Dogs, Therapy Dogs.
You know, all sorts of Demon Dogs.
And of course there's us, right?
But you know, having a job and a purpose is what makes us all the most happy.
I have another drawing.
This!
This is our home that we grew up in, you know, the Abyssgard home.
You know, our family, it consists of Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy.
Our home may look a little bit small, but it's actually really, really big.
Mama Puppy, Papa Puppy, and then us.
That's it.
You know, we did think that maybe it'd be nice to have like a little brother.
It'd be fun, you know, maybe bully them, make them do stuff for us.
But then also,
As for Papa Puppy... Papa Puppy?
Papa Puppy is a bit of a stricter BAU BAU kind of Papa Puppy.
He's a tough, tough one.
Papa Puppy might not really show his love outwardly, but it's very, very much there.
Deep down.
BAU BAU!
And the Mama Puppy!
She's a bit geeky too.
She really likes science fiction, novels, and games too.
But we didn't say anything, okay?
It's a secret because she finds it embarrassing for old dogs to play new games.
We didn't say anything, okay?
And we used to play games all together, but we're still just Puppies.
So Mama Puppy kinda sounds like BAU BAU.
Right?
But both Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy, they only speak dog and a little bit of English.
So you won't be able to meet them.
It'll be hard to communicate all together, you know?
But that's a little bit about us, about our upbringing.
And you know, we hope that that kind of brings us a bit more together, you know?
I think there's a lot of mystery up until now, no?
Well, the Makai is Wakai, and Northwest Passage is in the Makai.
It's easy to understand, right?
I would say that come visit, but it's best that you don't come to the Makai.
I think it's a bit difficult.
The human world is where all puppies belong.
Papa puppy, mama puppy.
That's their name.
That's what we call them.
Yeah, since we were just puppies.
You know, we could be like mama dog and daddy dog.
But this is what we've been calling them since we were little.
Yeah.
And no!
Momopapi and Papa Puppy are not single.
What?
No!
Everyone asks that!
Why is everyone asking that?
Ruffians are asking that!
Use your brain.
That's a little bit more about us.
A little bit more about us.
But let's move right into our next corner.
We have our Doggie of the Day!
De-den!
Look!
It's Cupcake!
She's the goodest girl.
I don't think there's any doubt about that.
Look at that face.
Right?
The radiant coat.
The beautiful shiny butt.
The nose.
It's just too cute.
You sort of feel like you want to boop it, but you can't just do a normal boop.
It has to be nose to nose boop.
Nose boops?
Nose to nose.
Moco-chan, that's...
Is that good of a nose?
That good of a nose?
Yeah.
She looks super sweet like a cupcake.
What do you think a cupcake sounds like?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And next we have... Today I went on a walk.
De-den!
This is a good walk.
It's so beautiful.
What do you think, Ruffians?
What do you think the best thing about this walk is?
This looks like a nice walk in Japan, maybe?
And all the beautiful scenery.
But there's a friend there too!
A cat with a good...
Behind.
You know, I think that if we were on this walk... Kurikaeri pose.
Yeah, yeah.
We'd probably go and quickly turn it into a run, right?
Yeah.
A sprint!
It's no longer a walk, it's time to run.
Yeah.
The tail's so cute.
Nice and round.
The thighs.
I think this was a very good walk.
Mococo, what?
No, this is a normal reaction!
This is a normal reaction?
Yeah.
Thank you, we're glad you had such a good one!
Yeah, we're happy you made a new friend.
BAU BAU!
And finally we have our Question of the Day.
We got a very good question.
Let's take a look at it.
I don't even know where to present this thought, but being a Spanish-speaking viewer, I've been eager to ask, what does Mococo, nicknamed Only Moco, think about her name literally meaning...
Thank you girls for everything you've done!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
It's embarrassing.
But... I think that as long as you remember that I'm Moco-chan, then... I'm happy.
I guess?
Yeah.
I guess Moco-chan is a pretty unique name then for you, right?
Then nobody else is called Moco-chan.
True, nobody would want to be named that.
I'm just happy to be the only Moco-chan for you, okay?
True, true, true.
That's a good way to look at it.
Yeah, yeah.
But... You wouldn't just crumple me up into a tissue and toss me away, right?
Right!
I'm not something dirty, right?
No.
I'm to be treasured.
You said it yourself.
Okay, well.
Right!
Let's keep on moving.
Maybe YouTube is a bit heavy right now.
YouTube.
Become light.
Bonk bonk.
Bonk bonk bonk.
Moving on.
We'll take a look at our very next stream here.
Then...
We're going to be playing Spooky's Jump Scare Mountain once again today.
We're going back.
We got to almost 350 of the thousand rooms.
It's been really scary.
But I just think that we made it pretty fun, right?
I think we did pretty good.
We were not very brave, but we did it.
But, you know, we're working together, all together.
You know, Moco-chan's being the feet and I'm being the run.
Right.
And then the ruffians are giving us all the advice.
Don't look behind or look behind.
Those kind of things.
Right.
I really hope that we can get to even more floors.
Maybe we can get to, like, 750?
Like, improve?
That would be cool.
That would be nice.
Yeah.
We'll do our best at the boss now, but... Yeah.
I'm a bit nervous.
Yeah, because right now with the boss, right?
We need to keep looking at him, right?
I don't wanna look.
I don't wanna look, and I feel like that's gonna be difficult, but... Do you think we can make it past him, Ruffians?
We better.
Our YouTube is back down!
Well, let's take a quick look at our schedule too.
We posted it on Twitter and to the YouTube community.
So, if you haven't seen it yet, you can see it in more detail there.
But, we're done.
Our schedule.
First, we have another FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
It was so much fun the other day, but this time, it's back with only hololive songs.
Only hololive songs.
Thank you so much for your suggestions over at the hashtag FWMCBEATS.
We already checked them all out.
It's been really helping us decide what kind of songs you'd like to see us sing.
If we don't sing the song that you'd like to hear this time, don't worry.
We will have more opportunities in the future.
This is just the first time, right?
I guarantee you we do want to sing that song.
It's just the first time.
We can only sing so much at once.
We'll also be appearing on Kiara-senpai's holotalk earlier that day.
It's gonna be a busy day, huh?
It's gonna be a busy big day, you know?
This will be our first collab with a senpai and a member outside of Alvin.
So we're really really really excited.
Please don't miss out on it, okay?
It's gonna be over at Kiara-senpai's channel.
You have to be there, okay?
Also, we want you to know there's been a little change.
We were planning on playing River City Girls, but we'll have to actually bump it to the future a little bit.
Just for now, just for now.
It'll be okay.
We're sorry to the Ruffians, we're really looking forward to it.
We hope you don't feel too disappointed.
We did our best, but there was nothing we could do this time.
But we'll be back to typing on the dead this time.
So we hope that you look forward to finishing it all together with us this time.
We really, really do everything we can to avoid any last minute changes like this, but sometimes, you know, it's hard.
We'll do our best.
We don't want to ever let you down, so...
We'll keep on improving, okay?
We'll do our best to do better, okay?
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today.
Ruffians, are you ready?
Chibi-ya!
BAU BAU!
Franklin!
Wolfkin!
BAU BAU!
Kellen!
Regi-boy!
BAU BAU!
Suzuri!
And to every other Ruffian out there,
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!